- Good morning believe nation, it's Evan.
My one word is believe,
and I believe in people more than
they believe in themselves,
and my sincere hope is that
if you see in yourself what
I see in you you'll be
able to change the planet.
So to help you on your journey,
today's message is learn how to sell.
Over to you, Robert Kiyosaki.
(rooster crowing)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
(laughter)
So I'm not as hardcore
as Robert is about sales
and hard selling as a skill that is
the most important thing to learn,
because that is one way to stand.
If you want to be great at sales,
it is a fantastic way to build a business,
but it's not the only way.
There are a lot of shy
entrepreneurs, myself included,
who have had success,
people you've never heard of
because they're shy,
and they just found another way to stand.
So again, if sales is your
thing, it's your forte,
or something that you want
to focus on and be great at,
then go for it because it's
definitely a great way to do it,
but again, it's not the only way.
When I took over this business,
Toronto Dance Salsa, I sat down with Alex.
We looked at ten different
ways to grow this business,
and I had him pick the
two that he really wanted
to focus on, and I gave him one which is
be thought leader and then okay,
pick the one you want to focus on.
Is it going to be, one of them was sales.
One of them was, okay, let's
go and start selling people,
start making partnerships with
different businesses and say,
"Hey, how do we have these
alliance things workout where"
"you can promote out
classes to your customers,"
"and we find some kind of
arrangement to make it work out."
He focused on something else.
He wanted to focus on providing
a great customer experience.
That's one way to stand.
If you provide a fantastic
customer experience
they will come back and they
will tell their friends,
and Alex came from a sales
background at a different job
so my initial thinking was
okay, we're going to have
a salesman come in and go and sell,
and it switched to okay,
we're going to focus on having
a great customer experience.
Because they're going
to tell their friends,
and they're going to come
back and be repeat buyers.
So that's another way to stand.
It could be you provide great marketing.
It could be you build a team,
and you allow the people underneath
you to bring their skills in.
It could be you're doing a thought leader.
It could be going through PR,
could be going through influencers.
It doesn't have to be the traditional
hardcore sales approach.
Now the one thing that
all of these things have
in common that if you want to have success
as an entrepreneur and
be a leader you're going
to have to figure out is
how to connect with people,
and if you want to see sales
as connecting with people
I'm okay with that, it's just not
the typical salesman
approach of I see that person
as my next suit or as I've
got to hit my sales quota,
and I'm going to force
them to buy this thing.
A lot of times sales are
seen through that lens.
If you see it as just
connecting with people
and helping them along their path,
the difference for me is really doing
the thing that is best for them.
Where a lot of times in sales
you're just trying to hit
your quota, you're just
trying to reach your market,
trying to push the customer
past their comfort zone so
you can meet your sales quota so
it's a very selfish
perspective as opposed to
this is actually what's best for them,
but if you want to form alliances,
if you want to talk to the media,
if you want to be a great leader,
if you want to be a thought leader,
if you want to write great marketing copy,
if you want to stand out on social media
you have to be able to understand how
to connect with people and move them
to take action as in their best interest.
I just want to let people
know that it's okay to be shy.
If you are shy you can
have a lot of success
as an entrepreneur, you
can have a lot of success
in a lot of different fields.
Ellen is an introvert which surprised me,
but has the biggest talk show on TV.
There's lots of different ways to stand.
It's not that this is the only way
to have success as an entrepreneur.
It works for some people,
but it's not going to work for you,
and the worst thing you can do,
the worst thing you can do is say listen
to somebody who doesn't look like you,
who doesn't believe
the same things as you,
and listen to them saying
this is the only way to do it,
and then feel like you can't measure up,
and you can't be like them,
and so you'll never have success,
and you'll try and try and try,
but you'll never beat through because
you're just not enough like them.
Where the best thing you
can do is find someone
who looks like you, find someone
who's an accomplished
success that believes
the same thing as you,
that has the same kind
of personality as you, and
be able to learn from them,
and say they did it, they had
success as a shy entrepreneur,
they had success as an
introverted entrepreneur
so I can have it to,
and so wherever you draw
the line between sales and being
able to connect with people
because this is super,
super, super important,
and if you see them as the
same thing that's great,
but if you see it as the hardcore,
you don't have to go down that path,
and you can have success if you are sky.
So the question today is
I'm curious how shy are you,
and how do you define sales?
Do you see sales the typical salesman
who's just trying to meet there quota,
or do you see sales as just
trying to connect with people
to help move them to
take some kind of action?
Really curious to hear your thoughts.
Leave it down in the comments below,
and also if you leave a
comment within the first couple
of hours of this video going live
you'll have a chance at winning
one of our two elite prizes.
I also want to give a
shout-out to Wouter Van Hecke.
Thank you so much for picking up a copy
of book Your One Word.
I really, really, really appreciate it,
and I hope you're enjoying the read.
Thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love and I'll see
you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of Entspresso.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
- For like an entrepreneur,
not, forget a sales person,
how about just an entrepreneur
who's looking to start a business.
Well, if you can't sell,
if you can't influence,
if you can't persuade, good luck trying
to get your business off the ground.
I'm not talking about just your customers,
I'm talking about the bankers,
the people at venture
capitalists, your vendors,
your credit card processor,
the people who work for you.
How do you get people
to work for you excited?
How do you get them excited?
How do you get them to want
to buy into your vision?
At the highest level
what sales really is is
the transference of emotion,
and the emotion you're transferring
is this emotion of certainty.
That someone feels certain.
Yeah, it's a good thing,
it's going to help me,
it's going to fill my need.
When you''re an entrepreneur,
and you're trying to start a business,
and you're recruiting people what
you're selling people on
your vision for the future,
your vision for this company,
if you can't do that,
good luck trying to get
great people to work for you.
It's almost, it's
significantly impossible,
which is why you always see the people,
they say oh he's a visionary.
Well, that's true, but
typically not only are
they visionaries, they
also possess the ability
to sell the vision to other
people to inspire them,
to motivate them, so selling is not just
like people thinking of selling,
oh well I'm not a
salesman, I don't need to.
Well, yes you do.
You need to learn how to influence.
How about trying to get
your kids to make their bed,
or do their homework, or believe
in the value of education?
How about trying to get a landlord to give
you a reduction on your rent or to extend
the lease the way you want?
How about trying to negotiate terms.
You understand?
It cuts to everything.
So I always look to
say, when I say I crack
the code on influence what
I really did, essentially,
was I just, by working backwards almost,
by saying I'm going to start at the end
and go to the beginning saying what has
to happen before someone says yes.
I was able to take that
and put it into this system that took
the no name talentless guys
and turned them into millionaires.
- Selling is something you'll always do
the rest of your life.
Most people don't like selling.
Some people like to kind of make it nicer
and say I'm going to use a better word
and say communication or this.
It's sales.
By the way, those who
just turn off the video
and don't want to watch
about what selling has to do,
hey, you want to marry that girl you love?
You know which one I'm talking about.
You need to sell her, and her
parents, and her best friends.
That's all selling.
You want to get that promotion?
Purely selling baby.
And those who get the promotions
sell better than you do.
That's why it is.
They don't sell a car.
They're job could be human
resource or something,
but they learn how to sell themselves as
that position more than you.
Maybe you ought to learn how to do it.
It'll benefit you, and
make you a lot of money.